hey guys I am here with actor and
activist and author and environmentalist
you have one more for me before I say
your name
that's a puppeteer puppeteer Ed Begley
Jr I did not know the puppeteer not of
course here I just wanted to embellish
my resume that was that was pretty good
a thing to do nowadays just Pat it a
little bit are you guys of course no and
from a zillion movies and TV shows but
what your real passions are I think your
real passions are really the environment
right even more than acting although
you've done a tremendous amount I have a
great deal of passion for acting but the
urgency is such that I have a lot of
zeal for environmental work now now more
than ever I started 1970 but now more
than ever so much of the stuff that
you've dedicated your life to so in line
with what we do here at riot which is
why I've been harassing you on Twitter
for about two hours to get in here about
a time and you came in so what I want to
start with is environmental studies now
cool but you were doing this stuff 30
years ago if not longer 45 works are 45
years ago so start there how did you get
into it and what possessed you to be
doing this when it wasn't cool cuz
everybody's doing it now right it was
very uncool to drive a three wheel
electric vehicle back in 1970 I can
promise you it was not a babe magnet
yeah I took Cindy Williams on a date the
one who played Shirley is over I'm
Shirley until they're in a date and my
electric field I'll pick you up my
electric car I first thought it was kind
of cool but I don't think I had fully
charged it or something right I was
going kind of slow there's a kid going
past us on hot wheels given it's a
finger not but how did you actually get
an electric car back then so you built
this yourself for now I bought it from a
guy named Dutch and I just looked up in
the yellow pages when I'm gonna just so
I can tell people I tried I'm gonna look
up under electric cars or electric
vehicles to see that they don't have
them I know nobody what the hell is this
electric cars I got told them they were
really they were really supposed to be
for like retirement communities they had
a California license plate but it was
basically a golf cart with an enclosure
you know like a and it was it was fully
legal I mean it was real Eagle I quickly
surmised it was much cheaper to plug it
in the wall than it was to buy 1970
gasoline same way my electric car my
Nissan Leaf is the same today it's
cheaper to plug it that into the wall
yeah than to buy 2015 gasoline just
cheaper so I like that and there was no
maintenance to speak of no tune-up or
oil change a fan belt radiator flush
smog check valve job none of that
anymore so I went I like this green
stuff but what really led me to it
before that electric car was living in
smoggy LA my dad was a very positive
person he was a a conservator light to
conserve he turned off the lights and
turned off the water save string and
save tinfoil so he was the son of Irish
immigrants he lived through the Great
Depression so he died within a few days
of the first Earth Day David and so I
did a lot of this stuff to honor him as
much as anything yeah so when you
started doing this did people think you
were nuts because right even now I'll
see some weird vehicle on the road yeah
that somebody's makeshift put together
I'm not talking about the leaf where the
Volt right some other thing it would be
like well what's that person they musta
thought you were bonkers I the electric
car was nutty but all the other stuff
people right away went that's good I
want to do that recycling in 1970 yeah
was quite cumbersome you had to drive it
to my electric car thankfully I would
drive it to you know like Sun Valley
only on Saturdays and Sundays between
12:00 and 3:00 could you recycle
anything glass aluminum anything a
newspaper so I took all that stuff they
are starting a 1970s started composting
and composting back then I was in an
apartment so I couldn't have a compost
pile I had like a little you know a
diaper pail with a lid on it you know
and I put all the table scraps in that
and I would take it what am I gonna do
with I saved it now I didn't think it
through what'd I do with it now an
apartment I near the railroad tracks
there's some land there nobody would
probably bothered me and I started going
the dead of night I'd dig a hole and put
this stuff just to return it to the
earth they kind of you know and suddenly
stuff was growing there where I was
burying this stuff and it was kind of a
great lesson because stuffs just started
growing from just burying organic matter
in the ground incredible and we still
don't really do that that much right we
should wait more composting programs so
just as an easy thing where to get more
to that kind of stuff later yeah anybody
has any piece of property with a front
or back yard grow some food you know
growing lawns there's kind of some rich
feudal lord left over or something but
you should grow some food that you can
eat and then also don't be trucking in
organic matter to amend the plants with
you know plant food make your own plant
food from your old table scraps and
grass clippings or whatever you got